yuppie charms because the queen is a
very last person to arrive I think that
looks like Prince Charles is birthday it
looks like Prince Charles is what he's
Bentley Oh is Bentley okay
very chic isn't it very and I do want to
mention out here outside of Windsor
Castle
but buzz about the crowd the crowd is so
excited people are waving flags down the
street and people are just this moment
is now buzz worthy because this is
something that they've waited for for a
long time and there is Doria Raglan as
she walks out of the car yes walking out
of the car with her daughter's it's
coming be brought in stunning Jim she
will be brought into the chapel and then
the car will loop around and take Megan
but that she would not get out of the
car with her daughter and they said
you're gonna be very surprised when she
gets up and how she enters the building
so I'm very curious to see exactly what
that means have they reduced the coaster
have they released to the dress no they
have not
I still neither one of you have been
able to say why they were able to keep
that a secret this is Prince Charles and
Camilla arriving 6 minutes and 48
seconds go ahead and go sorry girl
nothing I mean certainly in the old days
they used to black out all the windows
of the jurors yes and have people to the
on duty day and night to make sure no no
snoop has got in but it's very hard in
this age of social discipline to keep
anything secret put up the tent right
there is that why they add that is that
something special Ingrid
or Tina is that something special the
royal celebrations it's just an awning
so that you can visit of walking
supposing it was raining or something
beautiful Charles and commit and you
know Camilla is now actually very
popular not with the sort of so much
with the grassroots popularity of really
deep grassroots but she's beginning to
really win the British people over
because she's very looking at her right
now and looking at how she is she's
wearing green and purple today and
Prince Philip this is quite a this is
this is quite a good thing that
principle of his hair he's recently
recovering from hip surgery and there
was some question as to whether he would
be able to attend the ceremony today
I mean he's 96 and he is so stalwart
it's absolutely amazing just have this
hip operation as you say I think he
really wanted to be here as well to show
his support he loves Harry used to have
tea with Harry when Harry was at Eton
which is of course in Windsor just to
come over and see his grandparents as
did William
every poster to Prince Philip I mean
he's he's very much a grandfather who's
been involved and very supportive of the
boys particularly after Diana's death
always people say to him how do you
manage sir you know you're 1960's a
sheer brute force and bloody-minded you
I've heard Ingrid that they call him the
iron Duke the Iron Duke you know Harry
has some of his grunts or tub way with
words stay away I mean you know Prince
Philip he's always break for an epigram
yes we've heard that he's very candid
he's very manly brutally honest soon as
the Queen arriving she's about to step
out of the car and their principal if
once said you know world's can marry
chorus girls and sometimes even
Americans well it looks good you know
considering